what i want to do in this video is think
about the different ways to represent a
molecule
so the most obvious way is its name
so for example you could be referring to
a molecule of benzene benzene but just
the word benzene tells you very little
about what actually makes up this
molecule and there's other naming
conventions that do give more
information but you might say well i
actually want to know i want to know
more about the actual particular
elements that make it up
well that might be in that case it might
be useful to move up to the empirical
formula
empirical
empirical formula
and you might be thinking what does
empirical mean
well in general the word empirical is
referring to something that's
that comes from observation or comes
through experiments if you could say hey
you know
i i from empirical evidence i now
believe this this means that you saw
data this means that you you you have
some observations that make you think
this new thing and the reason why we
call what i'm about to write down the an
empirical formula is because early
chemists would have been able they can't
look they weren't able to look at a just
one molecule but they could at least
come up with they could observe the
ratios that it seemed like of the
different elements that they had in a
molecule so an empirical formula gives
you a ratio of the elements in the
molecule
so an empirical formula for benzene
is
it is
one carbon
for
every
every hydrogen
now you might say okay that's nice i now
know that if i'm dealing with benzene i
have one carbon for every hydrogen or
one hydrogen for every carbon but what
does but what what how many of each of
these do you actually have in a benzene
molecule
and to answer that question that's when
you would want to go to the molecular
formula
molecular
and the molecular formula for benzene
which is now going to give us more
information than the empirical formula
tells us that each benzene molecule has
six hydrogens
and i'm sorry six carbons
and
six
i'm really having trouble today six
hydrogens six carbons and
and six hydrogens now the ratio is still
one to one you get that right over here
it's very easy to go from a molecular
formula to an empirical formula you
essentially are losing information
you're just saying the ratio okay looks
it's a ratio of 6 to 6 which is the same
thing as 1 to 1. if we wanted to we
could write this as c1
h1 just like that to show us that the
ratio for every carbon we have a
hydrogen and we see that that's actually
the case in one molecule for every six
carbons you have six hydrogens which is
still a one to one ratio
but that might not satisfy you you might
say well ok but how are these 6 carbons
and 6 hydrogens actually structured i
want more information
and for that you would want to go to a
structural formula
structural
formula which will actually give you
the structure or start to give you the
structure of a benzene molecule a
benzene molecule would be drawn like
so you would have six carbons in a
hexagon so one
let me write this way one two
three
four
five
six carbons in a hexagon just like that
and then you have a double bond
every other of these bonds on the
hexagon is a double bond
and then each of these carbons are also
attached to a hydrogen also bonded to a
hydrogen
and each of these lines
that i'm drawing this is a bond it's a
covalent bond we go into much more depth
in other videos on that but it's a
sharing of electrons and that's what
keeps these carbons near each other and
what keeps the hydrogens kind of tied to
each or the hydrogens tied to the
carbons and the carbons tied to the
hydrogens so let me draw it just like
this
and this is only one variant of a
structural
it's hard for it's hard to see this that
one i just drew so let me see if i can
do a little bit
uh that's about as good hopefully you
see there's a hydrogen there
and there's a hydrogen right over there
this is one variant of a structural
formulas strum structural formulas will
actually give you some 3d information
will tell you whether a molecule is kind
of popping in or out of the page others
might might not be as explicit and once
you go into organic chemistry
chains of carbons are just done
they're just
you might see something like this for
benzene
where the carbons are implicit as the
vertex of each of is or there's an
implicit carbon at each of these
vertices and then you say okay carbon's
got to have is typically not gotta but
it's typically going to have four bonds
in its stable state well i only see one
two three well if it's not drawn then it
must be a hydrogen and that's actually
the convention that people use in
organic chemistry so there's multiple
ways to do a structural formula but this
is a very typical one right over here so
as you see i'm just getting more and
more and more information as i go from
empirical to molecular to structural
formula
now i want to make clear that empirical
formulas and molecular formulas aren't
always different if if the ratios are
actually the actual also show the actual
number of each of those elements that
you have in the molecule and a good
example of that would be water
so let me do water
so let me do this in a different color
that i i'm pretty much used every color
so
water
so water we all know for every two
hydrogens for every two hydrogens and
since i already decided to use blue for
hydrogen let me use blue again for
hydrogen for every two hydrogens you
have an oxygen
you have a high oxygen now it just so
happens to be that this what i just
wrote down i kind of thought in terms of
empirical form in terms of ratios but
that's actually the case a molecule of
hydrogen i'm sorry a molecule of water
has exactly two hydrogens and
and one oxygen and if you want to see
its structural formula you're probably
familiar with it or you might be
familiar with it each of those oxygens
and a hydrogen
each of those oxygens in a water
molecule are bonded to two hydrogens
are bonded to two hydrogens so hopefully
this at least
begins to appreciate different ways of
referring to or representing a molecule